[Music]
okay guys it could be any minute now
yep almost done
you know max was like
the sweetest guy ever
before he fell into a
pool of electric eels that'll do it
oh there it goes
are you okay oh
my back it's kind of stiff from all the
swinging i guess oh yeah no i got a
middle back thing too really yeah
you want me to crack it
yeah yeah that'd be great all right
you ready yeah
yeah that's good
that was it
wow
that's good you're right that's better
yeah
wow
god this is so cool
i always wanted brothers
so you like make your own web fluid in
your body i'd rather not talk about this
no i don't mean to are you teasing me no
no no no no he's not teasing you it's
just that
we can't do that so naturally we're
curious as to how your web situation
works that's all but if it's personal i
don't want to like pry but i just think
it's cool i i wish i could tell you but
it's like i don't do it like i don't
like i don't do breathing like breathing
just happens whoa like does it just come
out of your wrists or
does it come out of anywhere else only
only the wrists you never had a web
block because i run out of webs all the
time i have to make my own in a lab
that's and it's a hassle that sounds
like a hassle yeah but i i did actually
you said that i was like oh i had a web
vlog
why existential crisis stuff yeah i mean
like don't get me started on that hey
what are like some of the craziest
villains that you guys have fought seems
you've met some of them
that's a good question yeah i fought a
an alien
made out of black goo once oh no way i
found alien too on earth and in space oh
yeah he was purple i want to fight an
alien i'm i'm i'm still like that you
fought an alien in space
i'm lame compare like i fought a russian
guy in a like a rhinoceros machine can
we rewind it back to the i'm lame part
because you are not no thanks no yeah i
appreciate that i'm not saying i'm lame
it's just a self-talk maybe we should
listen though because you're you're
amazing just to take it in for a minute
yeah yeah yeah
you are amazing
you are amazing thank you yes will you
say it no i kind of needed to hear it
[Music]
we're gonna lift you up on a cherry
picker and you're gonna jump off
how they became super villains it's just
so funny i fell into a super collider
gotta be careful where you fall
to work with them is honestly the
highlight of my career me and toby
arrived and all of their arms were just
open
[Music]
[Music]
red butterflies with toby and andrew
hoping they would sign up
[Music]
you